what is up guys back at again with
another Godot tutorial let me just
preview the game that you are gonna
create it's uh let's see a 2d platformer
I don't know the gender of this game I'd
call the 2d platformer I don't care I'm
gonna hit command beat and run the game
just that I can preview the game I also
did this game in unity as well I called
it monster chase and I'm gonna call it
monster chase here as well so we have
our player over here he is moving and he
needs to avoid these monsters because if
they kill him if they get him in
apparently I'm very good at this game
come on man where's the monster here
from the left side because we're
randomizing here's another from the left
side and one when they touches me I'm
just gonna resize this as we can play a
little bit better but anyways when one
of these monsters touches me and you
just saw I'm gonna die
you see BAM boom I have died the game
has restarted so basically that is the
game but we will see how we can create
and control our player how we can create
these monsters how they can have their
own AI and how we're gonna do all of the
good stuff and you just saw so let's get
into the videos so the first thing I'm
gonna do is delete this editor or close
this editor because I have another one
and yeah don't mind my edit video
recording software over here so voila
here is our new project the first thing
that I'm going to do is I'm gonna create
a 2d scene and this one is going to be
gameplay so I'm going to call this one
gameplay and in the resources folder I'm
gonna create a new folder and call it
scenes and hit OK and in the scenes
folder I'm gonna save the gameplay scene
so go over there and save it now before
we continue let's go over here and
import these assets so these are the
assets I'm just gonna copy them these
rights you can download them link will
be in the description below so make sure
that you download these assets link will
be in the description below and what I'm
gonna do next is on the resources and go
here and locate it so open file manager
paste them so when I go back here in my
engine they are going to
I'm gonna click on the plus button right
here next to gameplay to open a new
scene because we're gonna create a
player and here I'm going to call this
one player because he is going to be our
player I mean what else can I say is
gonna be our player now in regards to
our player I'm gonna change the type
because currently the type is no 2d I'm
gonna right-click on it and I'm gonna go
here change type and I'm gonna filter
for kinematic body to D so kinematic
body to D because I want our player to
be kinematic body to D command as to
save this in the scenes folders the
command has to save it so what is the
first thing to do with our player first
of all I'm gonna click on the plus
button and here I'm gonna filter for
animated sprite actually not sprite
animation but animated sprite here it is
and I'm going to call this one animation
and let me just zoom in over here so I'm
gonna zoom in and this is our animation
for the player what we need to do is we
need to click on it so click on this
animation over here and for the frames
we are gonna click here new frames so
new sprite frames I'm gonna click there
and here we can creat our sprite frames
so the first one is gonna be idle and
for the idle let me just go here and
spry it's a player and I would drag this
one so this is our idle animation so the
first one the first frame nothing too
complicated next right here it says idle
you see this box or this document thing
and it has a little plus button at the
bottom right corner I'm going to click
on that and it will create a new
animation I'm going to call this one
walk and for the walk I'm going to
select all images from do up to seven
and I'm going to simply drag and drop
them over here so now selecting the
animation over here and clicking play
you will see that the animation is
playing but it's playing slow so I'm
gonna take here the frames per second
I'm gonna say 12 which is going to make
them you see it's gonna make them a
little bit faster so yeah this is what I
want and let me just go back over here
and turn off the playing and I'm going
to click here idle to play idle again so
now I'm selecting the player you see we
have this exclamation mark over here we
need to add
because this is a kinematic body we need
to have a shape on it so I'm gonna
right-click add the child node and
filter for collision shape to D and
attach that collision shape to D on the
player next go here inside of our shape
you see click on it and on the right
side you see we have the shape I'm gonna
click on that and I'm gonna select new
rectangular shape and I'm gonna zoom in
and move it something like this maybe
move it over here and resize it so this
is something you can do on your own this
is nothing complicated and I'm gonna
save it simply this is the body this is
the shape where we are gonna detect
collisions when it comes to our players
so when the player touches something in
our case a monster so when we touch a
monster over here as you can see on the
left or right side or up above or up
above above down anyways we are going to
detect that collision but we need this
shape in order to do that so now we have
the player and if I go here in our game
play and take the scene here and put the
player inside of the scene and if so I'm
gonna call lol on this one instead of
running the game I stop my screen
recording software okay that was awkward
so let us continue command B to run our
game which was which is going to brought
me to select which scene is going to be
the main scene when around our game and
it's gonna be game play so I'm gonna
double click here and it is going to be
game playing this is what we see now I
am going to resize this a little bit so
in order to resize it we need to go into
project and project settings and here
for in the window I'm just finding over
here where is it where is it here it is
window so the width of my project is
gonna be 1280 so HD by 720 the test
width is gonna be 640 and the test
height is going to be 360 so half of
this value and we're still not done
because if I go back here and run the
game you will see what we have you see
you see the players over here we don't
want that we need to go back again so
project and project settings and at the
bottom for the stretch it's disabled we
need to set it a 2d and ask
is gonna be keep and now when I come
back command B we're gonna see our
player and it looks really nice so now
we have our really really cool game it
looks I mean it looks like on the window
for HD resolution so what is the next
step to do let's go over here in our
resources folder and create a new folder
that I'm going to call scripts so
scripts folder and inside of that folder
I'm gonna right-click and create a new
script I'm going to choose here c-sharp
and let's go over here a new script and
I'm going to call this one player and
I'm going to hit create and it's gonna
create it and here in the gameplay scene
select are actually the player scene
select the player and go here for the
scripts and load it so from the scripts
folder we're gonna load the player
script then let me just double click on
it and open it in visual studio because
we are gonna use Visual Studio for this
and here I'm gonna keep it in the dock
or unfit from the dock so let's go over
here what do we need in our player
script what is that thing that we need
well we always need a couple of aerial
variables but before that let me just
tag the class and move a little bit down
and move this this here and this going
to be this is not gonna be processed but
it's gonna be physics process so we're
gonna have a physics process and here
above we are gonna inherit from
kinematic body so kinematic body 2d
instead of the node we're going to have
a private vector 2 which is going to be
hard movement and I'm going to call that
one by default vector to zero next we're
gonna have a private float which is
going to be our move underscore speed by
default I'm going to say it's 400 and
these variables are self-explanatory so
movement we're gonna use for the
movement speed we're gonna use for the
speed now moving forward we're gonna
have a private float gravity which is
gonna be equal to 20 I know gravity is
eight point nine point eight but I don't
care I'm going to set it in twenty
breaking the laws of physics over here
and we are also going to have a
private flow this is going to be our
jump underscore force by default I'm
going to say negative 900 we are gonna
have here also a private vector too
which is going to be up directions up
the IR is equal to vector to up like
this and basically that's that later on
we will have for animation here we will
have a private animated sprite which I'm
gonna call animation but that will come
don't worry about that now
inside of the player movement which is
something that we didn't create so here
player movement like this and inside of
the player movement is where we are
going to detect the input but first of
all let me just format this and call the
player movement inside of the physics
process so this is where I'm going to
call it now inside of the player move
and what we're going to do is we're
going to detect if our input so if input
that is key so is key pressed and or
actually is action so we're going to use
an action so is action pressed and the
action is going to be here in quotes and
I'm going to call this one move right so
move right and as you can assume I'm
going to duplicate this and I'm going to
say else if input is move left and also
here we're going to have else so we're
going to have all of these statements so
what is gonna happen next what you're
gonna do well if we're moving right
right we're gonna move the player right
if you ruin left we're gonna move left
but before that we need to copy these so
we need to go back here in our engine
and project and project settings and
here for the input map I'm gonna paste
move right I'm also going to paste move
left and I'm also going to type here
jump so we're going to have jump as well
now here for our move left or actually
move right I'm going to click on the
plus button and select the key and that
is going to be D so I click D on my
keyboard I'm going to click OK click on
the plus button and key again and right
arrow and click ok so now we have the
right key as well or the right arrow key
click on the plus button and key and I'm
going to click a now and click OK and
click on the pause button for move left
key and left arrow which is going to say
left that I'm going to click OK for the
jump click on it key space ok and now we
are good to go because now you see here
on our move right we have the D and the
right a move left a and left and our
jump we have space which means in our
game or in when we press that button so
here for the right when we press D or or
right arrow we're gonna move to the
right side and here for the left if we
press the a key or left arrow we are
going to move to the left and when we
press space we're gonna jump so what's
gonna happen here in our move right is
when we click on it we're gonna say
movement X is equal to your move speed
like this and when we press the left
button we are gonna say movement X is
equal to negative of move speed so more
speed so now we are have we have the
negative because the left side is the
negative side and here we have the
player movement I'm just going to tag it
because at the bottom of our player
movement we're simply going to say move
and slide which is a built-in function
from the kinematic body so here simply
we're going to call movement and we are
good to go now of course if I go back in
our engine command B to test this out we
are going to have some complications but
you're going to see what you see now
when I move you see first of all we
don't have gravity second I'm I simply
press the key once I'm not pressing it
currently I released it but he's still
moving you see press once and he is
moving to the right or the left side
depending on what key have I pressed so
this is awkward as you can see we
thought what our player to move like
this but maybe you want if you want to
you can leave the code like this but if
you don't in the else when we don't
press anything movement X is gonna be
equal to zero because here we're going
to reset it if I go back now and
actually need to go back to my engine so
command B if I go back in my engine you
see what's gonna happen
this and now when I release it he's
gonna stop when I move it he is still
there he is well stopping when I move
him he is moving when I release it he is
stopping so that's why I hear in the
else statement we need to set movement X
is equal to zero because if we don't
want to move then we need to reset the
movement back now also in regards to our
gravity here we're going to say movement
that y plus equals gravity which is
going to apply this gravity to our
player now as you can see it's gonna
apply this gravity to the player and if
I go back in our engine and command B we
are going to see that the player will
follow them now in order to fix that way
to go back here in our game plane first
of all I'm going to right click here and
add a child node I'm simply going to add
a node to D and this node to D I'm going
to move it here this is going to be our
BG parent and I'm going to duplicate one
and another one is going to be our
ground parent now the ground parent I'm
going to right click on it and change
the type is going to be a static body so
it's going to be a static body and I'm
going to save it but let's go over here
for the ground parent or actually for
the BG parent so let me just find our
background so we have the sprites we
have the player here is our background
so this is our background and I'm going
to put this one as the child of the BG
parent now select the background and
here I'm going to rename it to
background one because we're gonna have
multiple of these and let's go over here
in the offset I'm going to click on the
center so I don't want it to be centered
and for the transform I'm going to say 0
0 for X & Y and I'm going to duplicate
it so now we have background too and for
the transform of background two for the
Y position I'm going to say 700 or a
negative excuse me 720 which is going to
move the background over here as you can
see now how we're going to create our
backgrounds is that we are simply going
to move them by we are going to move
them if I select both of them and
duplicate them so now we have background
3 and I'm
to make it as a child so move it over
here so we have back around three and
background for if I go over here for the
transform and on the x-axis for both of
them I'm going to say 1280 it's gonna
move them as you can see right over here
so 1280 is gonna move over here
duplicate them again so now we have five
and six so copy these and 1280 and 1280
how much is that I'm not good in that so
yeah I have no idea about math so twelve
eighty plus twelve eighty that's two
five six zero so here I'm going to say
two five six zero as you can see right
here and again duplicate them so I'm
going to duplicate it we're gonna have
seven and eight so for these we also
need to add 1280 so how much is that so
1280 so let me just calculate that so
twelve eighty three thousand eight three
eight four zero so three eight four zero
let's go over here do the same thing for
these you get the point this is what you
need to do so let me just move the ten
over here and select the ten and nine
add 1280 so let me say here twelve
eighty five thousand and five thousand
and one hundred and twenty and this is
enough of course you're going to do the
same thing for the right side as well so
I'm going to duplicate here background
one and two let me just move it down so
now we have here no not as children of
background ten so that current that
needs to go over here so select these
two and now these are going to go on the
negative twelve eighty you get the point
so do that up to negative so up to
negative five thousand one hundred and
twenty and we're gonna do the same thing
for our ground so here for the ground
parent I'm going to select the ground
put it over here so this is going to be
our ground one like this and let me just
offset it so I'm not gonna
that I'm going to uncensor it so to say
so I'm going to uncentered the ground
and the first ground I'm going to
position at zero here and why is gonna
be six five two so yeah this is going to
be for our first girl I'm gonna
duplicate it move the ground over here
and not like this over here select it
and I'm gonna hold shift you put it
right next to the other one so select
the ground and this one let me just
select here the Y is going to be six
five two and the X is going to be four
hundred and fifty as you can see so 450
and I'm gonna do that for another ground
so let's go here for 150 that's nine
hundred we have the grounds here
currently we are going to have the
grounds all over where the backgrounds
are I'm just gonna test the players
movement so I'm gonna test the player
movements then I'm going to pause the
video form all of these grounds and then
you're going to see what we have but
before that select the ground parent
right click and add a child note and
we're going to add here a collision
shape because we need to do that and for
the collision shape I'm gonna go here
and select a wreck angular shape and
it's right here so what I need to do
with the collision shape is resize it a
little bit take the collision shape and
position it over here and let me just
resize it so that it fits the ground so
that we can land on it so if I command B
now so command B now we stand on the
ground you see we stand on the ground we
can move as you can see I still cannot
jump we will do that study from the next
video because I wanted to create these
grounds I wanted to create the
backgrounds and now we are moving with
the player and now I am going to pause
the video form all the grounds and the
backgrounds and come back so you can
copy a basis or simply download the
complete project and copy a basis all
back be back in a moment okay
I am back and as you can see what I did
I simply duplicated these backgrounds
and then I repositioned them i
duplicated the grounds and position them
so the difference between the grounds if
I take the ground one you see it's at X
position 0 Y position will be the same
so 652 that's for every single ground so
don't touch the Y for the X as you can
see the position for the first one is X
at 0 the next one is 450 which means
every next one is at 450 units to the
left or to the right side as you can see
so when I move these on the left side so
this one is going to be 450 next one is
going to be 900 because 450 plus 450
plus 450 is 900
so now take 900 and add to it 450 which
is 1,350 so add again 1 450 that's 1800
so on and so forth you get the point
this is to the right side to the left
side the negative 1 is the same numbers
but only negative so let me just find
here this ground I believe so from
ground 16 it's negative 450 then ground
17 it's negative 900 then 80 negative 13
hundred and 50 you get the point so
you're going to do this on your own it's
a bit tedious for you to watch me to
create all of this it's not fun but this
is part of game development so you need
to do it and the same thing for our
backgrounds so if you take a look at
here the first background so both of
these are at 0 for the X now for the Y
this one is at negative 720 so that
above one and every background that's
above you see we have two of these so
the one that's up it's at Y position
negative 720 only x position would
change and the x position will change
for 1000 or 1280 so 1280 so if for
example we have background one at 0 if
we want to add the next one to it then
it will be at X 1280 then the next one
is at X 1280 x 2 then by 3 you get the
point you just add to it the that value
and it will position it right next to
each other
I also added this moon just so it adds a
little bit depth to our game looks
so yeah nothing in particular will not
change our game our game can function
without it but basically yeah this is
this is setting up our level and
creating players movements so starting
for in the next video we're gonna
animate the player make him jump so
we'll see it that what is cracking
people in the previous video we started
our 2d platformer ish
game and we created our level and we
create the movement of the player but we
didn't animate the player and we didn't
make him jump so let's take a look at
how we can do that so I have the player
over here and in order to animate him we
need to get this component or this no do
you see animation because this is his
animation and in order to do that we
need to go back here and I already have
a reference to it as you can see but we
need to get the real reference inside of
the ready function so I need to say here
animation is equal to get note and not
name get note the note type is animated
sprite you see here this is the type of
the known animated sprite and how do I
know that if I go over here and how
we're over it you see the type is
animated sprite and now we need to
provide the name of the node that we
want to get so what is the name of it
it's animation like this and let me just
command B here to remove these so yeah
we also need to use the jump for so that
this right here will be removed like
this I don't know anyways it's
unimportant
so we have here the animated sprite and
we get it here from the animation what
I'm gonna do is go below the player
movement and here I'm going to create a
void function that's gonna animate our
player and I'm going to call this one
animate movement which takes two boolean
parameters one is gonna be bull moving
and another one is gonna be bull move
right and why do we need this well we'll
see in a second first of all if we are
moving so here if moving not move right
but if moving moving come on finally so
if we are moving then simply we're going
to call animation play and we're going
to play the walk animation how do I know
it's walk well if I go back here you see
I have two animations walk and idle
as you can see over here I have selected
walk now I have idle if you want them to
play so if you want to play one of them
if I want to play the walk simply click
or call play and call walk there you go
simple as that and here else if we are
not moving so else if we're not moving
simply we're going to go and call here
idle which is going to play the idle
animation no we are going to call this
inside over here so let me just take
this so here when we are moving you see
we're moving to the right which means
here I'm going to say true for moving
and true moving to the right signs you
can see move right we have here move
right and here we're moving to the left
so here I'm going to say true for moving
and Falls because we're moving to the
left side move right here is false and
here when we stop moving we can simply
say false here and here we can sound or
true or false it doesn't matter because
we will see in a second but I want to
demonstrate you one thing so if we go
back over here and I hit command B to
play our game which is going to run it
notice now when I start moving you see
he is animated everything is cool this
is totally normal right well wrong
because now if I go to the left side you
see the movie backwards except if you
want to have this kind of functionality
where your player is moving backwards
for I don't know what reason because I
don't know your weird so yeah anyways
you see if I click or hold command D or
command D just D or a or left arrow or a
right Thera what's wrong with me
you see he's moving he's being animated
but when he goes to the left side he's
not facing that side that's why I added
this right here move right why well
because if we are moving over here so
when we are moving I'm going to also
check if move right so if we're moving
to the right side else if we're moving
to the left side because if we are
moving to the right I need to go back
here and demonstrate that for you notice
where the player is facing he is
currently looking to the right side if I
select the animation which is our
animated sprite and go over here in the
inspector and for the properties you see
here I have something called flip agent
flip V Hey H is for horizontal V is for
vertical if I check
is on for age you see he's gonna flip it
and he's gonna start looking to the left
side as you can see flip it again he's
looking to the right side flip it again
left side you see what I mean
so when we flip it and by default as you
can see how this sprite is created
he is facing the right side so when we
don't flip it he's gonna face the right
side which means over here we're going
to call animation flip age is false
because when we don't flip it he's
looking the right side and here else if
we're moving to the left side we need to
flip it because as again I said that by
default this sprite is looking to the
right side how it's created so if we try
to move to the left we need to flip it
if I go back now and command B to run
our game you will see now when I go to
the right he is facing the right side
which is okay we're not flipping him but
if we go to the left pay attention you
see BAM he is flipping you see he is
flipping you know flipping anyways I
don't want to know you even though
you're annoyed but you're here to learn
so when we go to the right side now
everything is cool we are not clipping
him he is facing the right side if we go
to the left he is also being or he's
flipped and looking to the left side
which brings me back here in our else
you see here in the else statement when
we stop moving so here this these two
are four movements so if we move to the
right side true is for movement and true
and moving to the right if we are moving
to the left so movement is true so
you're moving and here false because
we're we are moving to the left side but
in the else statement we are not moving
so here we can say false or we need to
say false because we're not moving and
here we can say either true or false and
notice if I go back here and not over
here but the command B over here you
will notice that nothing will happen I
can move you see he is moving and
everything is fine if I stop the
movement he is facing the side where I
have stopped moving so if I'm holding a
key and I release it he's facing the
left and this is where he is gonna face
when when I release the button because
if you go over here in our animation
or enemy movement only if we were moving
we are going to flip him else if we are
not moving we're not gonna flip him and
that is basically what we are doing here
and this is how we can this is how we
can determine once you move when not to
move and want to flip the character so
moving forward what is the next step to
do now we need to jump and in order to
jump we have a built in function from
our kinematic body to D so this bad boy
over here so if I go here right above
our move and slide and moving slide is
also a function that we simply provide
so we call it it's built in into
kinematic body which will move into the
direction where we provided and we
provided movement here then we know we
are getting the movement over here so if
we press the right arrow key or the D
key we're gonna say movement X is equal
to MU speed if we press the a key or the
left arrow move speed is negative so
you're moving to the left or to the
right if we don't press movement X is
zero but here I'm going to test if is on
floor so this is a built in function it
will tell us if we are on the floor and
if that is the case if our input that is
key just so is action just pressed and
that action is going to be jump and if
you remember in the first video we said
the jump to be equal to space so when we
press space on our keyboard we are going
to jump but notice here so what is the
next thing to do we need to see movement
that Y is going to be equal to jump
force as simple as that you see movement
Y is equal to jump force if I go back
and in our game command B let's test it
out and see if it actually works so
command B if I jump nothing is working
what is wrong with teacher you're crazy
what are you doing calm down calm down
man I'm pressing space but it is not
working so what is the issue you see
here if I go back you we have the jump
and just to be 100% sure that I added
the jump so input map here it is so we
have the jump is space so yeah
everything was clear but it's not
working why well because you see here
move and slide we need to tell it if I
hover over
you see I don't know if you can see the
explanation you see here I have movement
slide which takes a vector to your
linear velocity but it also takes a
vector to floor normal what does that
mean we need to tell it where is the
floor we know that going down so in
Kedah engine when we go down and if I
take here my highlight tool highlight
going down and come on highlight so this
is the coordinate system this is the
y-axis this is the x-axis plus is over
here negatives over here for the X but
for the y- is up plus is down so when we
go down we are going positive we were
doing plus which means we need to tell
in which direction is the floor and in
order to tell that we have this right
here up direction you see up direction
because I'm saying up because this is a
shortcut for writing this new vector to
0 for the X 1 for the Y so this is that
shortcut so if i say here vector 2 up
it's the same thing as if I wrote vector
2 0 for x 1 for the Y so yeah I need to
get that out of the way but here we need
to provide that so we need to say here
up DRI so up the RI which essentially
will have a positive value which means
we're going down so now it will inform
our kinematic body that down is the
floor so if I go back now here and
command B to run our game let's see if
the floor will be detected in space you
get the point you see now it knows where
is the floor or the ground because we
told it it's down it's below us but we
also have one more issue I'm gonna go
here and I'm going to say GD dot print
which is it though for print and here
I'm going to say the value is like this
I'm going to say plus movement now this
movement over here is our movement you
see it's our movement over here that we
are adding to it you see over this
everything here that we are adding but I
want to show you one thing if I go back
here in our engine
command-b notice what's gonna happen in
the output we are going to print so
let's go here in the output you see the
value keeps increasing even though we
were just standing on the ground you see
I'm just standing if I jump you see the
value is at the value that we provide
but then it starts increasing and we
don't want that so I'm just gonna close
this you see we don't want that it's
increasing even though it's not gonna
hurt our game but maybe you will need it
for something else where it will hurt
your game if you have it like this so in
order to fix it we need to simply see
here movement is equal to moving slide
and here provide well simply movement so
everything else is gonna be the same
except here I'm going to say movement is
equal to move and slide and voila that
is that so if I go back now here and
command B so command B to run the game
notice now what's gonna happen here in
the output we're standing you see we're
standing but the output is if I clear it
you see the output is zero if I jump we
go up to negative 90 or 80 eight hundred
how much we set and then it's gonna go
back down again you see if I go over
here let me just find where we jumped or
it did we jump here it is so we jumped
so the value was negative nine hundred
then it fell down because we're
subtracting gravity as you can see over
here we're actually adding gravity you
see plus equals gravity then we move
down but then when we land on the floor
you see the movement value starts to get
zero zero zero zero and we don't want
that even though as I already said this
will not hurt our game the previous one
where we added the values but I just
wanted to show you that in case you
create some game on your own use this or
you use this code that I provided over
here and then you have issue so this is
how you will know what the issue is and
basically this is how we can animate and
move our player and starting from the
next video we will probably had the
camera so program the moving of the
camera then we will add enemies and yeah
wrapping up our game if you want to
learn more about Godot I have that in my
team Development Academy hopefully by
now I hope I have also blender in in
game maker and I'm working on unreal if
I don't have it already
click on the link below and I probably
have a month trial so I have one month
trial for two dollars you can try the
academy out for two dollars click on the
link below and you can learn from one
month for two dollars like yeah so yeah
I will see you guys in another video
what's cracking people back at again
with our 2d platformer games so in the
previous video we programmed the player
jump and we also programmed animations
now we're gonna make the camera fall the
player because if I hit the play button
command B to run the game we are going
to see that while our player can go
outside of this screen and this is not
what we want on the camera to follow him
that simple so uh let's take a look at
how we can do that then by the way if
you want to try out my Academy you can
do that link will be in the description
below try it out for one month for two
bucks even if you don't want to invest
two bucks then well yeah good luck
learning game development so yeah anyway
let me just go back over here why can't
I move this a little bit down so ya know
I can so if I go into the game played
this is what we have this is our scene
this right over here and let me just
draw said I can show you what I mean so
this over here this is our scene I'm not
sure if you can see these lines but it's
not important but that is what we see
and if I go back over here and let me
just fold all of this in the game
playing right click and add the child
now and I'm going to add the camera 2d
I'm going to call this bad boy main cam
and this main camera let me just go over
here in the transform of it and the
position for it is going to be 640 by
360 because half of the width and the
height of our screen shows we can
position it at the center but even
though we have the camera if I command B
to run our game we are still gonna go
out of the screen as you can see already
so how can we make the camera follow the
player first of all what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to click on the camera and
we're gonna create a script so let me
just go over here the script and right
click and create a new C sharp script
and I'm going to call that one camera
follow so let's go over here camera so
camera follow and I'm going to hit
create and of course select the main
camera go over here at the bottom and on
the script here where it's empty click
here to load it and we're gonna load it
from scripts in camera follow voila let
me just double click this bad boy and
open it this in our studio oh okay so
let me just tag this and let's go here
so what do we need everything or the
magic is going to happen in our override
let me just like this so that I can
format this correctly and we're going to
inherit from note to the instead of the
note only so no 2d the next thing that
we need to do is we need to get or
create a private note 2d for our player
so I'm going to call this one player
target and while we are going to use it
to get the player now also here we're
going to have a public pool player died
because when we die we don't want the
camera to follow the player and here in
our ready function we are going to say
here player target is equal to but first
we need to get the parent so we need to
see your get parent because if we just
use get node we cannot use this so here
we say get node it's going to be no 2d
like this and I'm going to call it
player I cannot just say this I cannot
just say get node Judi because the
player is not a child of the camera get
node so when you call yet node on a node
or on a game object it will try to get
the node that is a child of it that's
why we need to get the parent and the
parent is the game play so first we get
the parent then we get the child and let
me just go over here in the process if
the player has died we are going to
return now return me
simply exit out of the function because
if we have died if the player is dead
well there is no need for us to well
there is a need for us to continue to
follow him and besides that we are going
to kill the player move him out of the
game so that will not even be possible
so below if the player is not that we're
going to see in your vector to temporary
position is equal to the current
position of our camera next we're simply
going to say temporary position or
actually we don't even need to do this
we are simply going to say that bury
position is equal to your player target
so player target dot get the positions
are going to get the position from the
player target and simply we're going to
say position of the camera is equal to
temp and this is how we are going to
follow it and even so we can simply do
this so like this we don't even need
this vector to so we can simply say
position is equal to play your target
get the position so if I go back here in
my hedging command B to run it we are
going to notice now the camera is gonna
follow our player but that is not the
case and I told you the camera is going
to follow pay what is the issue now well
the issue is we need to so in the main
camera and we need to go over here let
me just find where it says so position
scale offset here it is inside of the
camera to D so we have the offset we
have the anchor rotating zoom we have
something here that is called current
let me just find it here it is current
this needs to be checked so when you
check that checkbox that means that the
current camera or what we currently see
will be the main camera so if I command
B to run the game now we will notice
that the camera now is following the
player say if I move to the left you see
the plat camera is following the player
if I drop the camera is following the
player if I go back over here again the
camera is following the player as you
can see you see you know we and now we
have the camera following the player and
I don't want to I don't want to resize
it's like this so what is the next step
to do well the next step to do is we are
going to add our monsters energy
and then we are going to start spawning
I mean our game and all the good stuff
anyways fire here for mr. calm if you
want to try out my can't develop macadam
e for one month you can do that two
bucks only for that link will be in
description below and yeah I will see
you guys in our video
what's up people fire your arses calm
and in the previous video we have the
camera following the players so what is
the next step to do the next step is to
create the enemies that put them in our
game so let us see how we can do that
but hey if you want to try my game
villain if it were trying about I get it
if you want to try out my game - like
enemy so now I have it right you can do
that for two bucks link will be in
description below so what we can do now
is here we're gonna click on the pause
button so this is going to be our empty
scene and this is where we are going to
create our zombies now let me just
double click on this note scene and I'm
going to rename this once you've read
zombie because first we are going to
have the red zombie now well actually
the green one whichever one you prefer
but what is the issue here is that we
need to change so I'm gonna right click
and I'm going to change the type of this
node because it is going to be a
kinematic body so yeah kinematic body
and I'm going to save that one here in
the scenes folder I'm also going
directly con it and I had the child this
is going to be our animated sprite so
click on the animated sprite and double
click on it and I'm going to call this
one animation because we're going to
need this bad boy and the selecting the
animated sprite let me just clear
everything here going into the animation
so clicking over here clicking here on
new frames we are going to create a new
frame this is going to be our walk
animation and this is the green zombie
so let's go over here and in the enemies
for the sprites we have the zombie green
select all these images so all the
images and put them over here so if i
zoom on our zombie and click here to
play you will see now the zombies
playing but I'm going to add 12 frames
so that he plays a little bit faster
because I believe 12 frames is okay yeah
12 frames is okay you can pump it up if
you believe it's not okay so yeah that's
up to you I'm gonna select the green
zombie game object and go here add know
that I'm going to add a collision
shape duty now for the collision shape
2d we need to select here a shape so
it's going to be a rectangular one and
I'm going to simply move this over here
in the middle and resize it so I move it
a little bit more in the middle
something like this and the zombies
animation is confusing me so I need to
uncheck it so that it doesn't play and
now I can simply resize this dude and
voila we are good to go so this is going
to be our green zombie this is
everything we need to do for him if I go
over here in our scenes I'm going to
duplicate the green zombie and I'm going
to call this one red zombies are going
to have a red zombie I'm going to
duplicate the green zombie again and I'm
going to call this one ghost
so select here the red zombie and double
click here and I'm going to change this
one to red zombie and selecting here the
animation for the sprite I'm going to
select all these frames or actually I'm
just simply going to delete all of this
and create a new animation for the walk
and go simply here inside of our folder
and select all the animations for the
red zombie and simply put them here
that's all we need to do everything else
is going to be the same and doing the
same thing for the ghost so here it is
ghost the goose goose goose goose goose
goose goose goose goose anyways here is
a ghost we need to do the same thing
select the animation here delete this
one so the walk one needs to go you
gotta go walk or no delete notes click
on the animation delete it click here on
a new a phantom and I'm going to call
this one walk let's go over here and
12:00 our frames are going to be 12 and
also for the red zombie over here I
forgot that we need to put the frames at
12 so this animation is well played and
let's go over here in venom YZ and we
have the ghosts select all the ghosts
put them over here and voila but for the
ghost we need to move this a little bit
here something like this can do just
resize a little bit more and if I play
it let's go here in the animation and
place our ghosty ghosty look at the goes
so yeah basically these are our
animations and I can go here inside of
the scripts folder and right-click and I
can create a new script this is going to
be a new c-sharp script so let's go over
here new script and I'm going to call
this one monster this is going to be a
universal script you're going to attach
it on the go so let's go over here and
load in scripts and monster so attach it
on the monster red zombie select it go
here on the scripts and load scripts and
monster green zombie go select it go
here scripts empty load and go under
scripts and monster so make sure that it
is attached on every single one of these
enemies and let me just go over here and
make sure that you check these
animations so that these animations are
playing so let's go over here the
animations are playing and let's go in
our visual studio and for the monster
what do we need first of all the monster
is also going to inherit from kinematic
body 2d make sure it's a kinematic body
- they don't make don't click or don't
select kinematic body only so it's gonna
be a kinematic body 2d let me just let
me just put this over here so what do we
need in order to move our zombies well
we need to move speed so it's gonna be a
private flow to move speed by default me
to say 600 because I want the zombies to
move fast as the speed of light we also
going to have a private gravity so
private float gravity which is going to
be equal to 20 F we are also going to
have a private vector so private vector
- this is going to be our movement and
you can see where this is going I'm
going to do the same the similar thing I
did for our player we are also going to
have here privateeer actually it's gonna
be a public one so here I'm going to say
public bull move the left to determine
if you're going to move left or right
and we're also going to have a public
bull is ghost and because we don't want
the ghost to be at the we don't want
those to be at the bottom or actually
landing on the ground because the ghost
is floating that's why we're going to
check if we haven't go so you're also
going to have here
private float minimum underscore X and a
maximum underscore X now for what you're
going to use these well simply here in
our gameplay I'm going to click on the
plus here and actually no not here I'm
going to click on this link which is
going to allow me to let's say for
example it adds a ghost and I'm going to
take the ghost and somewhere over here
okay so this is going to be the minimum
so the minimum is going to be negative
five thousand and ninety so that is the
minimum X so here we can go and we can
say minimum X is equal to negative five
thousand and nine hundred that I said
ninety bits actually nine hundred so I
can take the ghost now and not let me
just go here what did I do I put it as a
child of the main cameras let's see
negative five thousand nine hundred okay
it can also be here so yeah it can be
that value I don't care because we're
going to cue it that's why here let me
just go and not the background but
select the ghost and over here let's say
six thousand and six hundred and fifty
six thousand six hundred and fifty is
going to be the maximum X so let's go
over here maximum is gonna be equal to
this value again what we're gonna do is
we're going to have the bounce because
when the zombies or the ghosts or
whatever goes out of the screen we don't
need it anymore so we are going to kill
it we're going to cue it and that's why
we're using minima and a maximum what is
gonna happen inside of the already
function well we're going to determine
first of all if this that name is equal
to ghost so if the name of this game
object or this note holding the script
is the ghost we're going to say is ghost
is equal to true now we're also going to
check here if move left so move left
right here if we are supposed to move
left we need to say here move speed so
move speed is gonna be multiplied equals
two so multiply the 2 by negative 1 F
and then we're going to see here get the
note and the note is going to be
animated sprite and the name of that
note is animation and then simply we are
going to say flip horizontal is going to
be equal to true this is if we are
moving to the left side if we are moving
to the right side we're not gonna do
this but if we're moving to the left
then we are going to do it and simply
here in our physics process so here I'm
going to say underscore physics process
this is going to be the physics process
here we're going to say movement like
this dot Y and we're going to say plus
equals gravity but we are going to check
if this is not the ghost so if not that
goes that we are going to do that now
pay attention here I added an
exclamation mark what is an exclamation
mark well it makes what's after it the
opposite if this is ghost is true this
will make it the opposite which means
people make it false and voila
but if this is ghost is false then what
you're gonna do is well if it's a ghost
actually if it's not the girls excuse me
so here as you can see I'm adding is
ghost I'm saying it to be equal to true
if this game object or no it has the
value or name ghost so if this is not
the ghost you are going to add the
gravity and as I said if this is ghost
is true then this will make it the
opposite which is false and this right
here will not be executed but if this is
ghost is false this will make it the
opposite which is true and this will be
executed simple as that
and simply here I'm going to say
movement so movement that X is equal to
move speed and then we're simply going
to call your movement is equal to
movement slide and here we're going to
pass the movement simple as that and
that is all we need to do and we can
test this out and not go over here here
and in order to test it out I'm going to
go here and let's say I attach the ghost
so let's see let's see I have attached
the ghost that's I'm going to put the
ghost over here and I'm going to command
B so let's see if this actually is going
to work so now the ghost should come
from our right side or left side in we
that is the key
but the ghost also went out of the
screen so we need to kill the ghost
that's why we have the bounce so let's
go over here and what I can simply do is
I can test if the position that X is
greater than the maximum X or if the
position that X is less than the minimum
X we can Q free so we can Q free our
zombie or the ghost or whatever again
notice here if the position X of that
game object be that the ghost or
whatever if it's greater than the
maximum X Q free or if it's lower than
the minimum X then Q free this means
this is an or operator or however it's
called this means only one of these
needs to be true so this can either be
true or this can either be true if both
of these are not true only then we will
not execute this Q free but if this is
true if only one of these is true then
we will executing by the way notice here
I don't I didn't add parenthesis or
curly brackets because if you only have
one statement after the if statement if
you only have one line of code after
that you don't have to call you don't
have to call curly brackets so you can
do it without the curly brackets but
only if you have one line of code if you
adhere another line of code for example
int a is equal general 15 or 12 like
this then this one this right here this
in a will not be executed inside of the
if statement so again remember that and
we cannot test this out unfortunately we
can I mean if we follow our D mob Jake
and all of the good stuff but let me
just try to do this I'm gonna run the
game and try to run over here but since
I've added the value to the zombie he
will move faster than me you see he will
move faster and let's hope and here we
need to put the correct or arrange the
backgrounds correctly so yeah as you can
see we don't see him anymore you can do
the exact same thing to put the bounce
for the player this will be your
homework following this tutorial so do
the
same thing to put the bounce on the
player and here I made a mistake for
these bounds yeah for the background but
this is well easily adjustable so don't
worry about that anyways this was about
our monsters the next in the next we are
going to start spawning them in our game
then we are going to start detecting the
collision all the good stuff anyways if
you want to try my academy two bucks
only click the link below and I will see
you guys
howdy really no people moving forward
with our game let us start spawning the
enemies in the game so the player can
avoid him and all the good stuff and uh
yeah this is getting awkward let's get
into the game so the first things we
need to do is go here in the scripts
folder I'm gonna right click over here
and you see sharp script make sure it's
a sharp one let's go over here and I'm
going to call this one game play so game
play and make sure that you attach it
here on the game play game object so
script empty load we're gonna go under
scripts and I'm just like the game play
so first of all let me just double click
it and open here in Visual Studio while
we are waiting to open our script and
giving space all of this here if you
want to trav my Academy you can do that
for two bucks link will be in the
description below one month access for
two bucks just to try it out and if you
like it you can stick with it if you
don't well then don't simple as that so
here in our game play and we can inherit
note it's not a problem we need first of
all an export variable is going to be a
private packed scene and we are going to
have the green zombie so green zombie
red zombie and the ghost I'm a goose
goose goose goose goose and what is the
next step we also need a private vector
to spawn underscore left and we also
need and here of course I would say new
vector to like this and we need spawn
right this is the position where we are
going to spawn these game objects or
nodes or I want to call it let me just
go over here first
and I am going to take let's take the
red zombie and put it over here so
somewhere around here we can start
spawning this is on the left side by the
way so
the y axis can be 455 so here I'm going
to say comma 455 for the Y on both here
so comma again 455 for the Y and let's
go back so for the left side it's
negative 5010 or simply could be 5,000
and it could be 5,000 so let's go over
here and put it so what did I just do
command V to paste it okay so negative
5,000 this is for the left side and for
the right side we need to go back over
here and I need to take this bad boy so
let's take him and put him over here
positive six thousand three hundred and
ninety so here it can be positive six
thousand three hundred and ninety F this
is where we are going to start spawning
these or actually actually actually
actually let me just go back probably
here 6090 because let me just make sure
where is the bounds for the monsters so
yeah yeah it can be negative five
thousand and ninety let me just go over
here and see negative five thousand yeah
it can be like this and here six
thousand three hundred ninety because
here is the positive six hundred six
thousand six hundred and fifty so yeah
this can do so these two are going to be
are these are going to be where we are
going to spawn these enemies and in
order to spawn them we need to create a
function so I'm gonna go over here
remove this and I'm going to call this a
void on monster spawn underscore spawn
like this we are going to spawn the
monster now how we are going to do that
well it's gonna be very easy first of
all here I'm going to say int a random
enemies
and then me it's gonna be equal to new
random like this and I'm going to see
here next from 0 up to 3 this is going
to return a number between 0 and 3 but
not including 3 so it will return 0 1 or
2 and here we're going to say switching
case and here I'm going to pass my
random enemy and based on the case so
the value case can be 0 like this so
case 0 and like this and below in HC
break we were going to have case 1 and
case 2 so here case 1 and your case 2 of
course here at the top we need to say
monster and I'm going to call this one
new monster so new monster is gonna be
equal to null like this and depending on
here if we have case 0 we're going to
spawn a green zombie so we're going to
say new monster is equal to green zombie
that instance as monster like this and
here below I'm going to duplicate this
and this is going to be the red zombie
and here below I'm going to duplicate it
is and this is going to be the ghost so
depending on the random value here from
0 up to 2 so 0 1 or 2 we are going to
either spawn the green zombie the red
zombie or the ghost um girls girls girls
girls booze anyways what we are going to
do next is here I'm going to say vector
2 temp he is gonna be equal to or simply
declare it and I hear my fans going
crazy and not fans like you are my fan
but here let me just go and I would you
put them over here I think this is OK
so that we don't hear them and I don't
have to edit this and all of the
annoying things so the next thing that
we need to do over here is we're going
to again randomize here I'm going to say
new random and I'm going to call here
next from 0 to 2 if that number is
greater than 0 we are going to spawn to
the right side so here spawn to the
right else if this number is not greater
than 0 meaning it's a 0 so else here
below not packed scene but this over
here come on what you're doing like this
else we're going to see here spawn left
so what's gonna happen here is you're
ready to see 10
is equal to spawn right and here we're
going to say temp is equal to spawn left
like this but also here if we are
spawning to the right side our enemy
needs to start moving to the left side
so what we need to do is we need to say
here new monster that move left is equal
to true Y again if I go over here you
see if we spawn up to the right side
this is on the right side you see this
is our player and this is the right side
so our enemy need to start moving to the
left side so that is that that is the
reason why so let me just remove this
okay and practically the last thing that
we need to see here is new monster dot
set position we are going to pass here
temp and add the child new monster no
monster oh and voila now we can call
this here in the ready function so I can
spawn it here calling it in the ready
function let's go over here command B
just to see if this actually works will
this work will this work and we have a
debugger let me just see oh you see here
notice we have a normal reference
exception and the line where we have it
it's 31 and 15 let's go into 31 and 15
so 15 this is the line over here in 31
okay let me just okay you see this is
where we had that problem now the reason
for that is this I need to go and select
the game play I need to attach these so
here for the green zombie drag and drop
attach the green zombie for the red one
drag and drop attach the red one and for
the ghost drag and drop and attach the
ghost ever girls girls girls girls girls
and I'm going to command B now and
everything works but pay attention now
we are going to have a monster either
from the right side or from the left
side okay here he is so he is pawn we it
works but we only have one that is the
issue we only have one and in order to
spawn more we need to call this function
Ripley repeatedly over and over and over
again so let's do that
so right click here on the game play and
I'm going to click here add a child oh
this going to be
timer we need to go back over here and
this monster spawn let me just remove it
I'm not gonna call it in the ready I'm
gonna copy this name on monster spawn
because I'm gonna go here select the
timer go under his nose and signals and
select the timeout
connect the signal over here at the
gameplay so connect that signal and name
the signal on monster spawn and hit
connect but we need to select the timer
again go here in the inspector I'm going
to say let's say every two seconds and
how to start on its own one shot
don't check this if you check it it will
be only called once if this is not
checked it will be called over and over
and over again so let's see that and I'm
going to hit command B and now we should
see master spawning from both sides and
every two seconds we're gonna have new
mother okay this is a ghost ghost I'm a
goose goose goose goose goose we can
probably move the move the y-axis little
bit lower so that the ghost is not that
but you see we have one issue here one
issue and other issues so we have issues
here okay we have issues as you can see
and our game is lagging and all of the
good stuff you see okay we will see how
we can fix this starting from the next
video but what I'm gonna do is I'm
simply going to go back and probably not
4 5 5 let me just take the ghost and
position him over here where's my ghost
no not a child of a timer where is the
ghost here he is
and move the ghost over here when we
load it down something like this can do
transform here it's negative so oh
actually for the why not the X here I'm
going to say 3 5 so 5 3 5 this is going
to be our Y or actually yeah our Y so
here negative 5 3 5 5 3 5 so that the
ghost is lower a little bit lower to the
ground anyways this was our this is well
all for this video we're spawning the
monsters in the next video we are going
to detect collision between the monsters
and the player we are also going to see
how we can avoid collisions between the
monsters and all the good stuff if you
want to travel my game development
Kennedy you can do that for just two box
one month pass for 2 dollars if you want
it go get it if I'm not good luck
learning game development
that was you guys in another video what
is a cracking people this is the last
video of this series monster chase game
which is a 2d platformer ish game in the
dot game engine so let's get into it we
need to detect division between the
player and the zombies and kill him we
need to also prevent collision between
the zombies and themselves and yeah we
also need to restart the game when the
player dies so let's take a look at how
we can do all of that so yeah so the
first thing that I am going to do I am
going to go over here in our green
zombie and we are going to on do the
collision with the zombies so I'm going
to make sure that the zombies are not
colliding with each other so we can do
that by selecting the game the green
zombie game object over here the
kinematic body and here for the
collision I am going to set the layer
over here it is but the mask I'm going
to move it over here so make sure that
you move the mask over here do the same
thing for the red zombies so let's go
over here collision move the mask over
here also for the ghost select him
collision and here move the mask and
everything is gonna be okay simple fix
is that so if I commend B to run our
game we are going to see now that our
zombies are not hitting each other or
actually they can hit each other but
they're going to simply pass between
each other you see okay but I can
collide with them so I can collide with
them so they collided with me okay now
you see the zombie has passed then we
have another ghost and now you saw they
passed through each other so yeah you
saw it I'm not gonna repeat it again you
saw it you're not blocked okay what is
the next step well here I'm gonna go on
to player and select the player and
command B or actually right-click and
attach an area to D so I'm going to
attach an area to D and what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to zoom in on this
collision shape and I'm going to
duplicate this one and I'm going to
resize it like this or actually no no no
delete it why why did i duplicate it
resize the collision like this so simply
resize the collision like this but here
for the area TD I'm going to right click
and add
another collision 2d or collision shape
and here for the empty we're going to
select here a wreck angular shape but
this one this is so like this one I'm
going to resize this bad boy let me just
move him over here something like this
just a little more upwards no select
this one okay this one and voila
so these are going to be this is going
to be our collision now what we need to
do is we need to create a function so
select the collision area and go here on
their node and here we're going to
select this body entered so make sure
you select that connect it with the
player over here so connect is at the
bottom right corner and here I'm simply
going to call this function on body
entered and I'm going to connect it so
let's go into player and here I'm going
to say void on body entered which takes
a physics body 2d which I'm simply going
to call body what's gonna happen over
here well here we're going to test if
the body so if body is in group enemy
like this then what's gonna happen we
are going to Q free our player but first
of all let me just select this enemy
copy this so we need to go back here in
our engine select the green zombie and
here green zombie and where it says note
signals we have down the right side
groups so like the group and here paste
an enemy and click Add do the same thing
for the red zombie so here paste add go
here on the ghost do the same thing and
paste it and voila we're good to go so
what's gonna happen now if I command B
we are gonna go over here and when one
of the zombies or monsters touches as we
are going to see one thing first of all
we're going to have an error we're going
to fix it don't worry but let me just
show you that BAM you see we crashed our
our app crashed what happened here well
in the camera follow on line 23 camera
follow line 23 this is the error the
errors we are using the player target
but we have died this is what
are gonna use player died variable over
here so when we die the first thing that
I'm gonna do is I'm going to say get the
parent which is the game play parent
then I'm going to say get the node and
the node is gonna be camera follow so
camera follow and the name of the node
is gonna be main cam so main camera that
player died is equal to true so we need
to inform it you see player died is true
so that this right here will be true so
if player died we're gonna hit return
and we are not gonna follow the player
let's check that out so command B to run
our game again and see will that work
so now when one of the zombies touches
us we're gonna die but the game is not
going to so let's go over here and now
BAM you see I've died you see I've died
but the game is still on the game is
still on and we didn't crash okay so
what is the next step we need to restart
the game when we die and for that we're
gonna select our game play and go inside
so go inside of the game play and what
we are gonna do is here below I'm going
to create void so void underscore on
player underscore died like this and
here's something I'm going to say get
the tree dot reload the current scene
and here I'm going to simply say public
void player died like this and I'm going
to see here restart that start now what
is this restart well here on top we are
going to create a private timer that I'm
going to call a restart like this and
here inside of our ready function we're
going to say restart is equal to get the
node which is going to be our timer node
and I'm going to call it a restart like
this so now we need to create it so
let's go here and let's go in our engine
select the game play and add a child
it's gonna be a timer and double click
on it and rename it to restart we do
need to copy this function name so on
player dice to make sure that you copy
it and selecting that on or restart go
in
no than signals select the timeout
connected on the gameplay and paste here
so we are going to pace the armed player
dine and connect it everything is okay
the only thing that is left for us to do
is go back here in the inspector select
the timer and here I'm going to check
one shot and I'm going to see here too
which means after two seconds we are
going to call it so when we call over
here so when we call restart after two
seconds it will call this signal over
here
and wallah that is that and we are only
going to call it once that's why I set
here one shot to be true because we
don't want to restart the game 2000
times when the player dies and over here
in the player when we die so we get the
parent over here for the camera to
inform the camera that we have died but
we also need to say here get the parent
which is going to be our game play and
we need to say here player died to
inform it that the player has died which
will in term go back here in the game
play it will call this right here
restart start after two seconds it will
call this and we will restart our game
so if I command B now so command B let's
take a look at here what we have so here
and let's try to jump and now when we
die so let me just wait over here
because one of the monsters will show up
eventually BAM we died boom the game has
restart ok you see now congratulations
you have created a 2d platformer maybe
this is not technically a 2d platformer
but probably some of you wise guys will
will correct me and I don't care about
that you're here to learn I made the 2d
platformer because I didn't know the
giant the genre of this game anyways you
can download the complete project link
will be in the description below along
with this with the assets you can use
them for whatever you want to use them
of course you're gonna use it to
probably the tutorial but
congratulations you have created your
first game in the game engine my brother
and until next time bye here for message
comm if you want to track my game dev
Academy for 2 bucks one month click the
link below and I will see you guys in
another video